herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauerinnen
und liebe zuschauer
oder sollte ich besser sagen liebe
zuschauer innen oder liebes publikum wie
fühlen sie sich am besten angesprochen
sind frauen wirklich auch gemeint wenn
von grundschullehrern gesprochen wird
was ist sprachlich was ist politisch
korrekt verändert die sprache die welt
oder müssen wir die sprache an unsere
veränderte welt anpassen
geschlechtergerechte sprache wird
behördlich verordnete aber auf der
straße räte dann doch niemand so sender
gaga sternchen waren das sagen die einen
die anderen zb immer mehr
nachrichtensendung die sprechen
inzwischen so sendern überflüssig oder
überfällig unser thema in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich aus berlin
und darf ihnen meine gäste vorstellen
wir sprechen mit petra gerster vom zdf
moderatorin der heute nachrichten und
seit dem letzten oktober das ändert sie
sehr bewusst in der moderation schon
genommen vor gerster genannt und ich
begrüße professor werner patzelt
politikwissenschaftler er gehört zu den
erstunterzeichnern eines aufrufes des
vereins der deutschen sprache gegen den
gender unfug und herzlich willkommen
professor anatol stefanowitsch erst
sprachwissenschaftler der freien
universität berlin herzlich willkommen
und zugeschaltet ist uns auch judith
serien spessart sie ist autorin sie hat
germanistik und politikwissenschaften
studiert und bloggerin ist sie bei den
salon kolumnisten schönen guten abend
frau was hat frau gerster beginnen wir
mit ihnen seit oktober sendern sie
bewusst sie sagen zum beispiel chefinnen
und chefs sie sagen
ministerpräsidentinnen warum tun sie das
nein nicht sagt oktober das tue ich
eigentlich schon ich würde sagen schon
immer dabei sagt ich lege mich ja schon
nicht seit 40 seit mehr als 50 jahren
eigentlich mit dem thema
gleichberechtigung und frauenfragen
sagte man früher also frauenemanzipation
also schon in der schule habe ich setze
aufsätze geschrieben und in meiner
journalistischen ausbildung habe ich
dazu filme beziehungsweise erstmal
berichte geschrieben oder reportagen und
dann in meinem beruf beim zdf in den
wunderbaren frauen journal mona lisa das
erste bundesweite frauen journal
zehn jahre lang nicht mit diesen themen
befasst übrigens an der uni ich habe in
konstanz studiert auch schon mit sendern
mich auseinandergesetzt denn in konstanz
die berühmte feministische ließ den
luise pusch gelehrt ich war damals
allerdings etwas konservativer und sah
das ganze auch noch sehr viel kritischer
als wollte trotzdem wir sind hier die
diskussion hat fahrt aufgenommen weil
sie deshalb habe ich es gesagt dass sie
halt eben im letzten herbst bewusst so
auch wie ihr kollege claus kleber halt
eben diese form nutzen wo sie zum
beispiel sagen teilnehmer innen anstatt
teilnehmerinnen
teilnehmer an gespielt auf das sternchen
andere erreichen
das stimmt ja seit oktober ich wollte
nur sagen dass ich davor bei den
nachrichten also was ich das was ich
sozusagen weil man diese auch schon
immer gemacht habe wir haben also themen
mir auch mut zusprachen gemacht und auch
zu transgender menschen und sowieso alle
benachteiligung die frauen erleiden im
beruf rauf und runter also in zehn
jahren weckt man so ziemlich viel ab und
das habe ich natürlich in die
nachrichten auch mitgenommen also ich
habe schon versucht in den nachrichten
frauen immer auch mit zur sprache zu
bringen also zur geltung zu bringen da
wo es ging wo es sich anbot
das war natürlich meistens noch in beide
formen also männer und frauen dass man
beide nennt eben zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen und so diese einfachere
form des tendenz das ist aber trotzdem
aufgefallen frauen aufgefallen die zb
den deutschen journalistin bund der mir
im oktober dann dafür die täglich durch
urkunde zukommen ließ für meinen für
mein elegantes verändert haben es ist
genannt das hat mich sehr gefreut und
hat mir gezeigt dass das sozusagen
wahrgenommen wird und durch diese
auszeichnung aber habe ich dann mal
interviews gegeben unter anderem in der
taz und da habe ich erst mal angefangen
mich auch mit dem gender sternchen zu
beschäftigen das habe ich vorher nicht
benutzt und es kam mir auch immer
schwierig vor also ich muss zugeben da
war ich auch also sehr distanziert und
aber in dem ich es
während irgendwie doch damit
beschäftigte nahm ich es bei kolleginnen
war zum beispiel aus kleber und anne
will
die haben waren damit vor mir dran und
ich habe gemerkt es ist es ist gar nicht
so furchtbar also man kann ist
tatsächlich benutzen
vielleicht nicht exorbitant und auch
nicht man darf die menschen ja auch
nicht überfordern
aber so ab und ansätze ich es seitdem
auch ein und merke es geht also man kann
sich auch daran gewöhnen natürlich
gewöhnt sich viele menschen dicht dran
und haufenweise post die muss jede woche
in der ich nach dem wie moderiert habe
zehn briefe beantworten wütende briefe
vor allem von männern
aber ja das gleiche sehen sie das
genauso ist teil ihrer art frauen eben
zur sprache zu bringen
herr patzelt ist dass sie haben sie eine
petition unterschrieben gegen gender
unfug gegen des gender sternchen gegen
diese sprechen gegen diese schreibt ist
das unfug wasserwerfer macht ob etwas
folk oder unfug ist es stellt sich mit
zeitlichem abstand meist wesentlich
deutlicher heraus als in der jeweiligen
zeit war eine bestimmte ausdrucksweise
oder schrift mäßige darstellungsform
ungewohnt ist und ab und zu wie eine
marotte erscheint aber man muss er
ohnehin zwei schichten unterscheiden das
eine ist das dahinterstehende anliegen
nämlich die auch sprachlich geronnene
geringere sichtbarkeit von frauen zu
durchbrechen um frauen und insbesondere
auf sexuell diverse in dem schriftbild
dass man liest und in den klängen die
man hört sichtbarer zu machen und das
andere sind die grenzen auf welche ein
so löbliches bemühen
ab und zu auf grund von sprachlichen und
grammatischen strukturen trifft denn
natürlich tut man sich im englischen
ohne artikel und ohne
geschlechterunterschiede bei deckel
nationen wesentlich leichter mit den
schülern auf die deutschen noch mal die
frage finden sie es unfug das wasser
gerta macht wenn sie von
ministerpräsident innen zb erinnert und
es ist eine nette sache die darauf
hinweist dass inzwischen gottlob auch
frauen als ministerpräsidentinnen hier
an dieser stelle natürlich ohne pause zu
sprechen frauen als ministerpräsidentin
und haben und das kann nicht schaden
dafür sensibilisiert zu werden wichtig
ist warum schreiben sie denn hätte
unterschreiben sie eine petition gegen
gender und deswegen weil es gegen den
unfug ging sachen die man mit vernunft
macht und wo sozusagen der gute zweck
nicht durch marotten artiges entstellt
wird die kampagne unterstützen außerdem
ist es so dass sprache sich immer
gewandelt hat und warum soll sie sich
nicht auch in der weise wandeln das
geschlechtsunterschiede und geschlecht
identitäten stärker abgebildet werden
als früher
lediglich braucht es dann nicht dass ein
jeder dann stramm und zackig gleich an
erster stelle des fortschrittes mit
marschiert dann gibt es jene der allen
voran die anderen die sagen jetzt macht
mal halblang und dann wird man im lauf
der zeit sehen wie es mit dem wort des
heiligen petrus ausgeht alles prüfe das
gute behaltet und ob etwas wirklich gut
ist erkennt man zehn jahre macht neben
begonnen worden ist besser als ganz am
anfang okay frau was mit in den umfragen
wenn es um gender gerechte sprache
sprechen sich vor allem junge leute für
dafür aus dass man das ganz klar auch
benennt das man weibliche männliche form
benutzt sie tun das nicht sie sagen sie
wollen eigentlich nicht diese art der
sprache warum nicht wir haben ja also
auf einerseits gibt es zwei umstellungen
einmal die in unserer umfrage die vor
kurzem erhoben worden ist und dann noch
eine umfrage die welt die ganz klar
belegt dass mehr als zwei drittel der
deutschen bevölkerung sich ganz klar
gegen die gender strafe ausspricht also
ich glaube schon dass es in stent wie
sie sagen unter jungen leuten gibt aber
ich glaube die mehrheit der bevölkerung
hat überhaupt keine ahnung teilweise
auch was denn da überhaupt bedeutet ich
persönlich finde ländern unter stach
aktivismus der dahintersteht höchst
problematisch weil das stellen der
sprache nicht zu denken dass mit dem
postmodern weltbild das dahinter steht
und zwar gehen die aktivisten die
gendern erstmals stern verliert ist es
mit dem doppelpunkt oder auch immer
neutrale formen verwendet diese
aktivisten haben ein ganz spezifisches
weltbild das davon ausgeht dass die
unterdrückung der frau also die
herrschaft des mannes auf des weißen
mannes während der letzten jahrhunderte
so genannt war dass sich diese
herrschaft diese machtausübung in der
sprache verankert hat und dass wir diese
machtgefälle diese strukturen nur
überwinden können indem wir die sprache
verändern also dieser aktivismus
versucht politisch menschen zu einem
politischen gewissen denken anzuregen
indem man sprach leitlinien hat ausgibt
wie die stadt lübeck zum beispiel die
sagt man darf das generische maskulinum
nicht mehr verwenden oder man darf pro
nomen wie man oder
der nicht mehr verwenden also selbst ein
kleines bisschen wie er die auf ein
maskulines genus hinweisen müssen
unbedingt aus der sprache heraus
gecancelt werden ok rumänische
problematische ganz genau er das können
sie auch sehen also häufig wird gesagt
nein das ländern ist ja eigentlich dafür
da dass man in der sprache frauen und
männer und sexuelle minderheiten
sichtbar macht und es ist natürlich
wichtig dass wir in der politik auf
minderheiten eingehen er sexuelle
minderheiten auf jeden fall aber wie
wenn man sich anguckt wie diese sprach
forderung durchgesetzt werden und wie
vehement hier fast schon ressentiments
gegen den mann ausgelebt wird in der
wirklich assoziationen an männlichkeit
aus der straße hört wenn die man
ähnliche bilder oder selbst bilder im
kopf ja die an männlichkeit erinnern
könnten wirklich massiv aus der sprache
kennt sich also sie sehen neben der
chance haben sie wirklich
wir haben ja noch wissen wir bürgen ich
würde gerne stefanovic mit in die
diskussion um das mal noch einmal zu
klären also die frage inwieweit sprache
jetzt politisch benutzt wird versuchen
was man als sie als
sprachwissenschaftler flächen müssen
können sie es uns einfach nochmal
einfach erklären wenn es heißt wenn der
lehrer der bäcker ist dann auch wirklich
immer nur der mann gemeint oder ist es
eine
eine formulierung die so allgemein ist
das eigentlich beide gemeint sind ja
also das interessante ist ja im prinzip
ist es schon richtig dass wir sprache
nicht unpolitisch benutzen können aber
wir können eben auch den herkömmlichen
sprachgebrauch nicht unpolitisch
benutzen
der ist geprägt dass der ist geprägt
durch eine durch eine vorstellung dass
das männliche der normalfall ist
vielmehr brauchen wir da gar nicht rein
zu interpretieren also unter druck und
strukturen die es sicher gab ob die sich
in der sprache niedergeschlagen haben
das lassen wir mal dahingestellt aber
auf jeden fall die idee dass das
männliche der normalfall ist den mann
benutzen kann um alle anderen mit zu
meinen
das ist auf jeden fall etwas das ist auf
jeden fall das prinzip um das es hier
geht und wenn man das prinzip nicht
akzeptieren will und das hat zum teil
ganz praktische gründe
dieses prinzip nicht zu akzeptieren man
weiß zum beispiel dass stellenanzeigen
die im generischen maskulinum formuliert
sind dass das eine wirkung hat auf junge
frauen oder mädchen die über ihre
berufswahl nachdenken und diese
stellenanzeige lesen
also da gibt es gar nicht so sehr um um
irgendwelche ideologien von von einer
identifikation eid umfrage das geht im
prinzip um eine ganz konkrete frage
nämlich wer ist wer führt wer ist
angesprochen
wer gemeint ist na ja das können wir
alle immer nur selber wissen ja wen ich
meine wenn ich ein generisches
maskulinum verwende das möchte ich
niemandem unterstellen dem ableben
ähnliche fragen die männliche form
verbände und meine aber damit allerdings
nicht nur die männer ja nicht nicht dann
kann ich für die köpfe nicht stimmen und
kann nicht sagen diese person hat nur
männer gemeint aber ich kann sagen aber
er kann sein die die form wird so
interpretiert werden dass zunächst die
eine ähnliche vorstellung entsteht oder
natürlich wissen wir alle dass es die
praxis gibt männer zum anzusprechen und
alle anderen mit zu meinen und können
solche sätze deshalb verstehen ja aber
die aktive mitwirkung nach dem realismus
kann jedes mal ein bisschen kürzer reden
frau was hat sind kurz darauf und dann
würde ich gern frau gerda zu sprechen
frau was halt bitte also wenn sie in
einem stuttgarter kindergarten zum
beispiel und sie sagen den satz alle
stuttgarter essen gerne schokoladeneis
dann können sie ein vierjähriges kind
fragen und das kind fragen wer ist damit
gemeint sind damit männer gemeint nur
männer oder sind damit auch schon
gemeint und schon kleine kinder die
natürliche sprachgefühl des deutschen
haben oder auch menschen die nach
deutschland gekommen sind und gerade
deutsch lernen haben ein natürliches
gefühl für das gewehr schirmer screen um
ein generikum oder ein jens beschreibt
es so sagen dass menschen das sehen die
menschen verstehen intuitiv die
bedeutung des chinesischen maskulin und
sie sagte alle stuttgarter dann meinen
die auch jürgen die schokoladen als
vielleicht jeder dass es nicht dass es
genetische meinung nicht auf das
geschlecht verweist sondern auf die
gesamtheit der stuttgarter khedira sieht
man mal wieder die gesamtheit der sparte
die gesamtheit der psychologischen
forschung widerspricht diesem fiktiven
experimente und dem vorbehalt der rede
das kann man sich vorstellen dass das so
ist aber das ist halt ist es halt nur
eine vorstellung ag und und vierjährige
in china schon sehr viel input bekommen
dass es kann durchaus sein dass für ihre
kinder gelernt haben dass wir über das
wir über männer reden und andere mit
meinen dass in hat aber nichts daran
dass wir über mehr reden und die anderen
nur mit meinen also ein natürliches
sprachgefühl ist das mit sicherheit
nicht frau gestern wie sehen sie es ist
das ist mit der menschen immer der
moment frau bat im moment am meisten hat
jetzt ist der frau gas daran frau
gerlinde behauptung zu sein es ist also
wieder sozusagen frauen mitgemeint sid
ich habe mich selber auch lange
mitgemeint gefühlt aber das liegt
natürlich auch daran dass ich auch eine
selbstbewusste frau bin und vielleicht
nicht so abhängig war immer mit genannt
zu denen aber ich habe einfach auch
gelernt dass von jungen frauen auch in
meiner familie 20-jährigen studentinnen
die einfach jetzt soweit sensibilisiert
sind dass sie sagen
es stößt mich geradezu ab wenn in einer
sprache einfach das heißt wie lehrer und
und die erzieher im internet und in
büchern und so weiter und wir wissen
dass also schon die mehrheit der lehrer
nämlich lehrerinnen sind und die
erzieherin mit 90 prozent frauen
das ist einfach der realität nicht
gerecht wird und insofern muss ich frau
wasser wirklich widersprechen weil es
ein umgekehrt ein schuh draus wird wir
benutzen nicht ändern um sozusagen die
wirklichkeit zu verändern sondern
sprache beschreibt ja die wirklichkeit
und entwickelt sich der wirklichkeit
journalistinnen sind ja einen
resonanzraum und wir haben wir in
praktischen zusammenhängen und leben
sprach und erleben wirklichkeit und das
entwickelt sich parallel und sprache
bildet das ab und natürlich ist es
unsinnig wenn wir jedes wort gender
und wenn man sagt ich gehe zum bäcker
wenn es sage ich auch nicht geht es um
becker dann meine ich nicht in
männlichen becker der das steht dann
fräsen sondern ich meine die pks
institution wenn wir vom
bundeskanzleramt sprechen dann ist die
institution gemein da muss ich nicht
bundeskanzlerin amt sagen nur weil er
gerade angela merkel residiert übrigens
leider auch nicht mehr lange
er soll das in institutionen und wir
müssen es einfach nicht übertreiben wir
können das doch wirklich von contex
abhängig aber da will ich sage ja hinter
haben morgen bewahren dann dann sind
natürlich alle in der gemeinde und dann
assoziiert man nicht nur männer das ist
klar aber die arbeiter die entspanntheit
die sich jetzt ansprechen die haben ja
nicht alle herr passe wie empfinden sie
die diskussion man hat ja im moment sehr
das gefühl dass es irgendwie sonne
ja das ist auch eine ideologische
diskussion ist von von verschiedenen
seiten wie woher kommt das haben
haben sie das gefühl ihn wirklich
sprache weggenommen hier kann man die
sprache nicht wegnehmen
da muss man eine ganz andere sprache
kommen ich rege mich auch nicht darüber
ob ich sehe die sache so wie es vor
gäste beschrieben hat wenn man vom
bundeskanzleramt spricht muss man das
nicht notgedrungen gendern und solange
sich die meisten frauen vom begriff der
mensch angesprochen fühlen und ich
glaube man muss von menschen und
menschen entsprechen ist die sache auch
in ordnung das was vielerorts unmut
auslöst ist sozusagen das unnötige
gendern wo es um das prinzip geht um das
was vorhin als die mögliche politische
agenda hinter dem kentern angesprochen
worden ist da merkt man dann ab und zu
eine absicht und ist verstimmt und
manche das muss ich auf meinen eigenen
erfahrungen sagen manche warten ja
förmlich darauf dass irgendein man
insbesondere an einer bestimmten stelle
nicht ordnungsgemäß beide geschlechter
idealerweise unter einbezug von
geschlechtlich diversen anspricht und
verwenden dann dieses versäumnis auch
wenn es ledige sie aus leichtfertigkeit
und nicht aus ideologischer verbohrtheit
geschehen ist nutzen das ganze als
angriff und weil man dann merkt es gibt
eine unfaire ebene wo sozusagen nicht
mehr die gleichberechtigung im
vorbringen von sachlichen argumenten
zählt sondern das sich identifizieren
oder nicht identifizieren mit einer
dahinter stehenden agenda
dann ist man verstimmt da kommt das gift
in die debatte und das tut uns nicht gut
und an
sie ist das soeben ja auch schon zu
erleben gewesen wo merken sie denn wo
haben sie denn sprache verändert sagen
sie profess studentin sagen sie
studierende wie machen sie das
ich verwende seit den vielen jahrzehnten
in denen ich gelernt habe immer schon
beide formen
ich habe glaube ich nie das verpönte
wort fräulein verwendet sprach immer von
damen und herren sprach immer von
studentinnen und studenten
ich habe ein problem mit den
studierenden denn wenn sonntag oder
vorlesungsfreie zeit ist ist dann ein
studierender ein studierender oder sind
dramatische formen inzwischen
sinnentleert ist ein rad fahrender auch
einer der das rad gar nicht fährt
sondern schiebt oder kommt es uns auf
die präzision von begriffen nicht mehr
an
verstehen sie das sind dann die
dimensionen wo es selbstzweck artig wird
wo es aufgesetzt wird und das müssen wir
vermeiden
dann kommt der sprache gerade passiert
ob sie auch also ich verstehe das gut
weil ich mich auch lange gegen
studierende gewehrt habe weil ich das
irgendwie hässlich finden htc aber haben
sie diese vorbehalte auch bei der
vorsitzenden oder bei den vorsitzenden
seit menschengedenken sagen wir
vorsitzender wir sagen wir sprechen
bleibt menschenmengen von reisenden und
nicht von reisen und reisen und wir
sprechen auch von anwesenden also das
stürzt uns ja nicht in sofern möglich
ist auch dass der eingewöhnung ja ein
anwesender ist halt tatsächlich anwesend
denn wäre er das nicht wäre ein
abwesender aber ein studierender der
pause macht studiert eben gerade nicht
und weil ich nun einmal heimlichkeit
habe aber ich wollte gerne ihnen gerne
nach fühle stört mich das alles stört
mich nicht so dass in der leidensdruck
daraus entstünde verwendet werden dann
müssen sie auch noch gesagt egal dann
hätte noch ein zweites mal hingucken
weil das verb studieren
das wird nicht so verwendet wie sie das
gerade behauptet haben wenn ich sage
mein sohn studiert jetzt an der freien
universität berlin dann ist das eine
aussage über ein status den er jetzt hat
und nicht über eine tätig ein paar
klassen soll das ist ein ganz normales
jahr war einer dritten person wenn ich
sage er studiert an der universität
berlin
auch wenn er gerade pause macht ändert
das nichts daran dass er ist das ist der
gehalt widersprach geht dann ist er auch
einfach turnier male anders und denn
akzeptiert man eben solange er nicht
marotten artig wird ist alles so machte
er das partizip bei
hält aber diese eigenschaft des
zugrundeliegenden werbefrei und das werk
studieren bezieht sich auf keine
konkrete tätig war in sachen beratung
märklin radfahren ist es interessant
weil der radfahrer in der tat nur ein
rad fahrender es wenn er auf dem rad
sitzt und das interessante ist in der
verkehrs in der straßenverkehrsordnung
wo er ja seit einiger zeit auch als
radfahrer behandelt wird da meint man
ihn auch nur wenn er auf dem rad sitzt
da meint man ihn gar nicht wenn das
einrad schiebt sie gerne sprachliche 14
die frage dieser diskussion ist ja
irgendwie ziemlich hat ja fahrt
aufgenommen viele regen sich darüber auf
und sagen jetzt wird das alles
vorgeschrieben und wir haben jetzt ja
eben ja auch schon mitbekommen jetzt ist
die frage muss die kann sprache wirklich
etwas verändern erste fahne wird oder
soll sprach immer nur abbilden von dem
was sich verändert hat also die tatsache
dass eben 89 prozent aller
grundschullehrer weiblich sind muss sich
das nichtwiederfinden in der sprache
also man darf natürlich die man darf
nicht die fähigkeit von sprache
überschätzen
unser denken zu prägen das sie tut es an
was sie tut es natürlich nicht in
irgendeinem deterministischen so quasi
en bildschirm sinne es ist jetzt nicht
so dass wenn wir plötzlich anfangen
würden durchgängig das gender sternchen
zu verwenden dass uns auf magische weise
sich unser denken ändern würde und wir
plötzlich eine viel gerechtere welt
hätten aber da weiß man schon sagen kann
dahinter
ich glaube ein teil der absicht ist die
eingeschliffenen gewohnheiten zu
durchbrechen
denn die hindern uns tatsächlich häufig
daran über dinge mal anders nachzudenken
und ich glaube das ist auch eine große
eine große chance dieser form vielfalt
die wir im moment sehen der tatsache
dass es eben in diesem ganzen bereich
der des sogenannten gender nicht eine
form gibt die dominiert sondern dass
verschiedene menschen da verschiedene
dinge ausprobieren und das bedeutet dass
wir auch immer weiter die aufmerksamkeit
so zu sagen dafür behalten
ich glaube diese die tatsache dass wir
hier sitzen und darüber diskutieren in
gewisser weise ist das eine konsequenz
davon dass bestimmte leute angefangen
haben eben dass die gender lücke oder es
im gesprochenen oder das ständer
sternchen der geschriebenen sprache zu
verwenden
also da hat der sprachgebrauch bereits
gesellschaftliche debatten angestoßen
und er hilft uns auch einfach
in diesem trott zu verfallen und und uns
mal zu hinterfragen
irgendwie denken wir eigentlich wenn wir
sagen wir gehen zum freibad was würden
sie denn sagen wie wichtig wie oder
haben sie den eindruck dass durch dieses
sender sternchen das binnen i und auch
durch verordnungen die es gibt das
stellenausschreibungen männlich weiblich
divers jetzt heißen dass dahinter eine
klare politische absicht steht und
finden sie das falsch also bei
stellenausschreibungen finde ich das
ganz natürlich dass man meine stellung
schreibung hat und dahinter männlich
weiblich diverse streit durch jeden fall
da sehe ich nicht das problem an solchen
sachen wenn man das geschlecht sichtbar
macht wenn es wirklich um eine konkrete
person ist besteht die man einstellen
möchte also ich sehe das problem eher
wenn landes landesregierungen oder
städte oder der redaktionen anfangen
diese sprachregelung die wie gesagt
immer mit der aus meiner sicht schon
klassen eliminierung des männlichen aus
dass strache und teilweise auch das
weiblichen wenn diese forderungen von
oben durchgesetzt werden also machen sie
sich auch als die menge an so der
student kann ich mein punkt machen und
wenn sie also ich finde das argument der
gerechten abbildung finde ich bisschen
strom an argument verwendet sie sich
angucken wie diese straf- leitlinien
durchgesetzt werden dann sehen sie dass
es hier nicht darum geht um höflichkeit
es geht nicht darum sexuelle
minderheiten wirklich sichtbar zu machen
sondern es geht darum gewisse werte aus
der sprache komplett heraus zu canceln
und eben beim gedanken und assoziationen
und auch bilder im kopf der patienten zu
steuern und das ansagen
zeitungsredaktionen ganz explizit sie
haben im dlf der die leute einfach
nachdem er seine sprach leitlinien genau
der deutschlandfunk nach dem gender
leitlinien herausgegeben hat hat er noch
mal ein statement herausgegeben
wieso er das gemacht hat unterstand
wirklich explizit dass sprache bilder im
kopf erzeugt gewisse assoziationen und
ein gewisses embed bild hervorruft und
das ist jetzt aufgabe der direktor de
ist dieses weltbild und diese bilder im
ob der menschen zu steuern ähnliches
haben sie im land berlin auf das land
berlin hat die länder leitfaden
herausgegeben
und dort steht ganz explizit dass es
darum geht handlungen und meinungen der
bürger zu lenken
und wenn sie so ist es also wenn wir
eine macht institutionen haben die von
oben herab setzte kempten aber auch die
eigenen bürger zu gewissen politischen
handlungen bewegen möchte dann ich muss
es in dieser ehrlichkeit sagen dann kann
es dass am totalitären verhalten ok und
das merken die werten auch genommen aber
jetzt ist man ihnen etwas verkaufen
falls ja was soll also was sagen sie zu
dem findet diese einlassung einfach ist
schon gar nicht potenzieren denken in
eins gesetzt wird das geht entschieden
zu weit
also ich kenne niemanden der etwas
überstülpen will und das ist vor allem
ist ja eine verschwindende minderheit
die im moment geändert
die große mehrheit nicht nur der
bevölkerung sondern aber auch die große
mehrheit noch einen medien geändert
keineswegs als benutzt schon gar nicht
das sternchen sondern die sprache ist
etwas konservatives und es dauert lange
und ich kenne niemand der jemand anderem
etwas überstülpen will ich akzeptiere
auch jeden und jede die das nicht
verwendet und die ein generisches
maskulinum okay findet man man kann ihn
nicht mit irgendwelchen dogmen arbeiten
oder irgendwelche es gibt auch keine
sprachpolizei dass verwaltungen machen
dazu kann ich nichts sagen sagt damit
habe ich mich nicht beschäftigt aber ich
weiß nur dass natürlich das generische
maskuline mit dem wir alle aufgewachsen
sind
wenn das gebäude nicht genauso eine
ideologie ist wenn man von ideologie
sprechen wollen eine welt anschauen die
den mann zum maß aller dinge macht und
das kann man an verschiedenen stellen
überprüfen das ist zum beispiel auch in
der wissenschaft so in der medizin zb
werden alle versuche und medikation und
so weiter an einem durchschnitts wenn
man von 75 kilo und einer bestimmten
größe ausgerichtet und es könnten das
war wissen wir inzwischen von von
forscherinnen es können viel mehr frauen
überleben in der medizin
wenn frauen da zum beispiel mehr
einbezogen würden also es geht überall
darum dass frauen eben nicht sichtbar
gemacht werden
in diesem eher nass aber die frage ist
ja ob es erfolg als dementi die
männlichen experten die wir im fernsehen
sehen ich denke jetzt ist er passe da
also auch die politik erklärt
wir sind auch zum fast alles männer ist
leer hat sich der falter ortet wie sie
alle heißen
es sind wenig frauen die da sichtbar
werden und jetzt fangen wir erst an
parallel zu diesen ländern auch darüber
nachzudenken ob es nicht auch weibliche
von die politologin gibt die leute aus
erklärt aber frau gerster kann man denn
so kann man es kann man es sagen
und jetzt haben wir ja auch biologen
entdeckt und und und ja aber das ist
doch mal bei der sprache bleiben also
die frage ist wenn jetzt in behörden vor
allem wenn jetzt wird alles muss immer
geändert werden in allen texten müssen
diese muss das gender sternchen genutzt
werden hat das eine auswirkung her passe
glauben sie dass das funktioniert ist
das etwas oder ist das etwas bei ihnen
dass sie sagen dass das finde ich
eigentlich nur negativ und erschreckt
mich eigentlich eher ab also wenn
klingende sprache oder geschriebene
sprache überhaupt keine folgen hätte
dafür die leute denken fühlen und die
welt kognitiv organisieren
dann könnten wir den kampf gegen die
verwendung des wortes als oberbegriff
für sinti und roma oder den kampf gegen
das n-wort einstellen weil die begriffe
die worte die wir verwenden ohnehin
keinen einfluss hätten natürlich haben
worte haben wendungen einen einfluss und
natürlich hat schon die
erwartungshaltung wenn jemand von
staatssekretärin spricht das gleiche
staatssekretärinnen auch genannt werden
eine folge dafür dass man sich klarmacht
dass es natürlich nicht so ist oder gott
sei dank nicht länger so ist dass
bestimmte berufssparten bloß angehörigen
eines geschlechtes zugewiesen sind
infolgedessen verändert sprache schon
bewusst sein und denken nicht in der
weise dass man die ganze welt verändern
könnte bloß weil man die winkel
verrichte weit darf das gehen wo es für
sie deine grenzen
die grenze kann man nicht objektiv 10
denn
vieles hängt davon ab wie man vorgeht
vieles hängt auch vom zweck ab ob der
zweck ein lobenswerter ist oder nicht
die faustregel ist die wenn erwachsene
leute in einem land anfangen sich
obrigkeitliche erzogen zu fühlen wenn
erwachsene leute den eindruck hat mir
wird nun obwohl ich meine 40 50 jahre
auf dem buckel vorgeschrieben wie ich
reden muss wie ich dann auch denken soll
dann sind die leute verstimmt und nicht
ganz zu unrecht verstimmt und das ist
dann für mich immer ein zeichen dafür
dass auch in einer guten absicht sie mit
allen mitteln verfolgen
das sind eben verfolgt diese guten
absicht überzogen worden ist und das ist
die stelle wo der gender gaga einsetzt
gegen den ich mich verwahre nicht gegen
die dahinterliegende gute absicht okay
herr stefanovic
warum kann eigentlich jeder reden wie er
möchte genauso ist es ja und auch die
behörden auch die kommunalverwaltung
hannover zum beispiel die tatsächlich
eine dienstanweisung die ihre ihren
gender leitfaden im mit dem instrument
einer dienstanweisung für die eigenen
angestellten verpflichtet verpflichtend
gemacht hat macht das ja nur für die
eigenen angestellten und auch nur
solange die im dienst sind
und dass das ein dienst erkannt im
öffentlichen dienst das wissen wir das
weiß herr patzelt das weiß ich dass man
eben als als beamter oder angestellter
im öffentlichen dienst eine
loyalitätspflicht gegenüber dem
dienstherrn hat und dass die auch solche
dinge beinhalten kann das ist jetzt bei
der breite gender gerechten sprache
keine ausnahme sondern das ist nur ein
beispiel unter vielen die die person
kann ihren stift fallen lassen um am
freitag um 13 uhr
man kann nach hause gehen und natürlich
kann sie dort sprechen wie sie will und
die kommunalverwaltung hannover wird
wird keine dienstrechtlichen maßnahmen
ergreifen die bevölkerung an die
bevölkerung durch den anderen leid für
denken wenn der wagen steht nicht in die
die dienst
sachen so schreibt wie vorgeschrieben
dann kritisch und dann kriegt der arge
genauso wie ihr ärger kriegt oder sie
wenn sie an anderen stellen
dienstanweisungen verletzt das ist der
preis an zahllosen haben bevor ich den
restlichen dienstherr sein kann und da
ich sprach und da finde ich mach der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk das
bisher dort wo er es tut sehr gut
nämlich da dort der deutschlandfunk hat
ja keine leitlinien die irgend etwas
vorschreiben sondern der hat eine eine
handreichung für die eigenen
mitarbeitenden in der eine bandbreite
von formen nicht etwas sage zur
verfügung also quasi dargestellt wird
und in der mitgeteilt wird dass jede
person dort frei entscheiden darf was
sie sich aus diesem spektrum aussuchen
inklusive das geld ihres kollegiums also
der rein männlichen form ok und das ist
auch der richtige weg diese die die
sprachpolizei wenn es sie gibt würde ich
eher an bestimmten stellen vermuten wo
versucht werden soll dass ländern zu
unterbinden oder diese neuen formen zu
unterbinden das ist das eint ist die
einzige gruppe sehen sie denn wenn wenn
eben
solche petitionen für die ich an patzelt
nicht alleine verantwortlich machen will
aber er hat sich ja mit unterschrieben
das ist im prinzip ein versuch
sprachpolizei zu spielen nicht die
kommunale einrichtung werden dem kunden
es ist nicht so als ob alle wenn manche
leute vorangehen einverstanden sein
müssen aber in einem fast freien staat
ist es ganz normal dass die eigenen
dieses wollen die anderen das andere und
sich dafür artikulieren deshalb mit
polizei nichts zu tun das ist die
freiheit eine meinung nicht nur zu haben
sondern sie auch zuhörer dies verletzt
diese meinung überhaupt niemand dann die
massiven frau gerster nicht verletzt da
doch wenn ich sage man kann es auch
übertreiben nicht aber andere ab und der
vorsitzende des vereins deutsche sprache
der auch diese petition angestoßen hat
der hat die letzten monate damit
verbracht alle alle verantwortlichen im
öffentlichen rechtlichen rundfunk
anzuschreiben und hat sehr wohl versucht
lobby anzulegen muss ich zu stellen dass
seine unterschrift das ist die sprache
hat sie wollten was sagen und dann oder
frau das dann auch so was zudem nicht
öffentlich erklären also da gibt es
noten
das ist also im zdf zum beispiel auch
keine kleine handreichung gibt und keine
oder keine keine linie gibt die wir
befolgen müssen sondern dass wir als
journalisten und journalistinnen so
ernst genommen werden dass wir das
sozusagen der sender uns vertraut dass
wir verantwortungsvoll mit der sprache
umgehen
sprache ist unser handwerkzeug und das
sollte man auch erwarten dass man da
reflexiv auch damit umgehen
im übrigen möchte ich nicht und dazu
angehalten sind demokratische grundwerte
wie zum beispiel die gleichberechtigung
von männern und frauen auch mit
voranzutreiben das ist ein
demokratisches finden uns vertreten das
ist unsere demokratie auftrag der dazu
ist die frage ob die gleiche richtung
damit vorangetrieben wird frau was hat
sie sehen das glaube ich ein bisschen
anders
auf gar keinen fall also da müssen sie
sich nur die letzten 60 jahre der
frauenemanzipation angucken um zu sehen
dass sprachliche regelungen überhaupt
nichts mit
situation der frau zu tun hat also in
den 60er jahren war es für eine frau
noch unmöglich ein eigenes bankkonto zu
besitzen oder ohne die erlaubnis des
ehemannes überhaupt arbeiten zu gehen
west und sexualität wertes krankheit der
homosexuellen szene ist gelangweilt dass
diese massiven rezessions mechanismen
konnten wir überwinden ohne dass gender
sternchen ohne irgendwelche straff
regelungen sondern in dem staun für ihre
rechte gekämpft haben und staunen sind
in dieser diskussion keine opfer
erstaunt sind individuen und ich finde
es auch falsch dass durch das gender
strache frauen irgendwann wieder in eine
gruppe eingeschätzt werden ihn sie immer
wieder als frauen sichtbar gemacht
werden nicht alle frauen möchten immer
auf ihr geschlecht reduziert werden das
muss man dann diese diskussion auch mal
sein
und jetzt noch zu einem anderen punkt
weil sie sagen in der redaktion wird das
ständern nicht vor bestehen natürlich
wird das nicht vorgeschrieben aber wenn
sie sagen dass das ländern der sprache
und das herauskitzeln von männlichkeit
das so weit geht dass man nicht mal mehr
das wort man sagen kann weil man angst
hat dass im kopf zufall männlichkeit auf
block und dadurch dann frauen auf einmal
nicht mehr
emanzipiert genug sind das ist übrigens
auch eine these die sich
wissenschaftlich überhaupt gar nicht
beweisen lässt aber immer irgendwie in
behaupten um das rechtliche regelungen
das hat dann sagen geschlechtergerecht
darf ich kurz mein punkt machen in
welche richtung steht das unheimlich
doch mal was ich und ich konnte jetzt
die ganze zeit nicht werden wenn sie
davon ausgehen dass solche stark
natürlich wird ein modernes stück
aufgebaut wenn sie sagen dass solche
regelungen gender gerecht sind und
garantiert in eine gerechtere welt
führen dann ist es ja klar wie derjenige
aussieht der immer noch dass genetische
maskulinum dann wären wir ja wie ein
reaktionärer menschenfeind und gläser
moralische druck den haben sie an
universitäten ich habe mit studenten
geredet die angst haben ihre wenn sie
ihre arbeiten abgeben hausarbeiten und
nicht gitter natales glaube ich dass sie
sollte ein dass die anzeigen
zum aufstellen der vaart ich möchte 100
euro ist ein guter ist ein montag hat er
auch ein blick aufs klo ich sitze
einwohner sagen 100 deswegen haben wir
einen punkt gemacht sie haben sie sagen
das moralische druck geht ist japanerin
ist jetzt eine belohnung von 100 euro
aus für jemanden der mir einen studenten
bringt oder auch eine studentin oder
eine studentin studieren kann ich
repressalien erleiden musste weil sie in
einer hausarbeit nicht ändern kann ich
bin sofort kann sofort sehen ob gerade
weil so viele leute seien zu machen die
fünf jahre leute ich kann ihnen auch
publikationen zeigen innerhalb der queer
feministischen bewegung wie heute da
massiv unter druck
das ist aber ein anderes thema keks dass
solche publikation gebrauchen also genau
das gleiche was hat genau das ist ja
ganz verschlossen glaube ich frau
gestern einfach nicht so stehen lassen
kann ist was war passiert sagt dass also
frauen sozusagen zum ausfall gemacht
werden wenn eine weibliche änderung
angelegt würde ich mal das gegenteil ist
der fall
frauen werden damit sichtbar gemacht sie
werden als individuen und als als
subjekte gekennzeichnet die eben aktiv
an dieser gesellschaft teilen haben und
die sonst verschwinden im generischen
maskuliner und einfach nicht nicht zum
tragen kommen das ist dann der hübsche
pointe dass wir dieser tage 50 jahre
gefallen nicht gefeiert aber gedacht
haben der abschaffung des fräuleins vor
50 jahren
und sie glauben doch nicht im ernst
verbessert dass es keine wirkung gehabt
hätte die abschaffung dieses wortes was
übrigens sicher auch gegen eine mehrheit
der bevölkerung war weil sich ja viele
ältere herrschaften das fräulein sehr
hübsch fanden und so entzückend und sich
ungern davon getrennt haben aber
natürlich hat die abschaffung dieses
fräulein sind frauen erst mal bewusst
gemacht dass sie auch ohne ehering und
ohne mann und ihrer seite vollwertige
mitglieder dieser gesellschaft sind also
bewirkt frage sprache schon auch einen
emanzipation
das ist einfach ein historisch gedacht
ich würde gern mal auf den auch er wie
ich würde gerne mal die letzten minuten
nutzen um mal ein bisschen nach vorne zu
gucken wo man vielleicht sich auch
finden kann
weil das ja jetzt haben wir uns an diese
ständer sternchen teilweise schon
gewöhnt es gibt diese neue form mit dem
mit dem kleinen mit der kleinen pause
vor dem innen ist das gibt es da
vielleicht noch was anderes herr
stefanovic wo man sagt sprache muss sich
ja verändern kann man oder wird sich die
einfach wird sich das sowieso von selber
verändern weil viele junge leute das
auch einfach jetzt so benutzen also ob
sich eine der aktuell verwendeten formen
auf breiter ebene durchsetzen wird
das würde ich nicht wagen vorherzusagen
ich glaube dass wir tatsächlich sehr
sehr am anfang dieser entwicklung stehen
es kann sein das ist eine kurzfristige
mode ist es kann sein dass das in ein
paar jahren ein backlash gibt das kann
sein dass das alles wieder verschwindet
es kann auch sein dass irgendjemand die
geniale lösung einfällt die dann uns
alle zufrieden stellt jetzt den anderen
sachen einfach einem englischen zb wir
können natürlich auch wir können auch
500 jahre warten dann wird vielleicht in
deutschland auch die art von von laut
licher abschleifungen von wort
änderungen stattfinden die im englischen
dazu geführt hat dass das thematische
geschlecht verschwunden ist dann werden
wir sehr viel leichter haben als heute
soso in der situation in der wir jetzt
sind glaube ich dass wir möglichst viel
vielfalt hier zu lassen sollten in
dieser frage möglichst viel kreativität
und es wird sich am schluss tatsächlich
ich glaube dass vielleicht die einzige
meinung die die herr patzelt nicht
teilen das wird sich im rückblick zeigen
was ist ob das richtig war was davon
richtig war und was davon mehrheitsfähig
aber die frage passt wie empfinden sie
es wie sehr kann man sprache kann man
dann sozusagen das auch steuern wir
haben das in der ddr gab es nicht die
sekretärin da gab es den facharbeiter
für schreibtechnik da gab es nicht den
führerschein sondern die fahrer erlaubt
ist also man hat bewusst bestimmte
begriffe einfach geändert
ist das sinnvoll wenn man das von oben
macht hat sie dann bis heute sagen alle
fahrerlaubnis in aus deutschland die
absicht kann glücklich sein wenn die
absichtlich und die mittel akzeptabel
sind dann kann man das natürlich so
machen und aus einem stadtführer eine
stadtbild erkläre zu machen und aus
einem führerschein eine fahrerlaubnis
weil der führer normal im deutschen
nicht geht das ist plausibel und hält
sich deswegen auch was in der zukunft
ganz gewiss bleiben wird das ist die
bereitschaft und auch der sanfte zwang
des besseren argumente es diesbezüglich
weibliche und männliche form an
weibliche und männliche endungen
gleichberechtigt zu verwenden idealer
weise
auch in einer 50 zu 50 verteilung was
beginnt aber mit dem männlichen oder
weiblichen beginnt wenn ich es darauf
anlegen würde hier die rolle des agent
provokateur zu spielen würde ich
freilich sagen bedauerlich finde ich
dass genau jene sexuell diversen um die
wir uns zu recht mehr bemühen als früher
dass sie genau in der kunstpause des
gesprochenen sterns zu verschwinden
haben stadt auch ausgesprochen zu werden
aber an dieser stelle merkt man dass man
es auch nicht allen recht machen kann
es ist schon eine sehr erhebliche
veränderung der sprache eine die ich
begrüße im übrigen dass wir männliche
und weibliche formen hintereinander
immer verwenden
aber jetzt auch noch sämtlichen sexuell
diversen dass ihnen zukommende wort
zuzusprechen
das würde zumindest die verbale
kommunikation sehr erschweren
in frage so eine ganz gute lösung in
folge dessen wird an dieser stelle
sozusagen ein eine stelle aufgemacht wo
im schweigen wo in dem leichten klick
laut von frauen und sowas wo in diesen
leichten klick laut eine ganze welt von
sehr unterschiedlichen lebensentwürfen
verschwindet nur ist das ein
vergleichsweise kleiner punkt aber wäre
ich einer von den sexuell diversen würde
ich diesen punkt ernst zu nehmen als wir
ihn in der auf männer und frauen
fixierten debatte ihn meistens behandeln
und wo wären die grenzen frau gerster wo
wäre für sie eine grenze in der taz gab
setzten einen artikel da ging es um
desolate zustände in ein
flüchtlingslager und da wurde über
menschen mit gebärmutter gesprochen wenn
ich jetzt ganz korrekt wäre sparen
müsste ich ja fast sagen menschen mit
gewehr elternteil also das wäre ja dann
das dann wäre es ja in einer art
durchgezogen die man die ja eigentlich
für uns erst mal absurd klingt ist das
ein punkt wo sie sagen ja das ja da geht
es zu weit oder ist das eine entwicklung
muss sagen ja eigentlich ist es aber so
muss man in die richtung gehen
ich habe diesen braucht jetzt noch nicht
auseinandergesetzt
es scheint mir erst mal absurd weil es
einfach 20 uns einfach möglich ist
gebärmutter ist mit ihrer mutter und ich
weiß nicht was daran falsch sein soll
das sind auch immer so extrembeispiele
mit dem versuch das ganze zu ändern
irgendwie ins unrecht zu setzen
wir schreiben den zuschauer und sagen
sie demnächst auch die papierkörbe oder
irgendwie hören welche absurden sachen
werden angeboten um damit klar zu machen
ist das ganze absolut ist ich finde das
nicht nicht redlich ich finde wir
sollten einfach ja auch so ein bisschen
den schaum vorm mund weglassen und das
bisschen gelassener sehen
es ist tatsächlich geht es nicht um
leben und tod ist es erst mal nur
sprache und wir sind da bin ich völlig
der meinung von sowohl von herr patzelt
als auf meinem herrn stepi stepanovic
wir sind in einer umbruchphase gerade
ist bewegt sich es ändert sich ganz viel
und wir probieren auch ganz vieles aus
und insofern ist natürlich diese debatte
die wir jetzt führen ja auch schon eine
positive entwicklung des spenders oder
eine positive wirkung ja auch schon
bewirkt dass er uns einfach wieder dass
wir mehr darüber nachdenken wie wir
sprachen verändern und wie wir
minderheiten sichtbar machen
übrigens verschwinden die nicht in dem
geld passiert ist und ich habe gelernt
dass gerade das stände sternchen von
diesen gruppen gewünscht ist weil es
eben nicht nur die lehrer dann frauen
männer darstellt sondern eben auch die
anderen
inwieweit ist glücklich ist und wie weit
es sich durchsetzt sage ich auch die
erste von mir wissen es nicht wir
vielleicht wenn wir in zehn jahren noch
mal diskutieren anschauen was ich
durchgesetzt und wir gehen auch nicht
davon aus dass die ganze literatur
umgeschrieben oder stefano ricci also
der ich glaube dass vorurteile und ich
kenne keine forderungen bisher
literarische texte umzuschreiben
aber ich finde es eine interessante idee
der literarische texte werden immer
wieder mal umgeschrieben aber ich kenne
solche forderungen nicht mehr
ok ich sehe schon vielen dank frau bat
vielen dank frau gerster wir hätten hier
noch weiter darüber streiten können auch
aber wir sind am ende unserer sendezeit
vielen dank herr patzelt stefanovic
machen sie es gut sie können diese
phoenix runde auch bei spotify hören da
ist es ja dann noch ein bisschen anders
wie dann die sprache wirkt also tun sie
das auch gerne und bei nächster woche
ist mein kollege wieder für sie da bis
dann
[Musik]